[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سي
ابي عاصفه الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من القدس
وتصلنا هذه الصور مباشره من المسجد الاقصى
يصلون ومعتكفون بعد اقتحامات متكرره من
قبل مستوطنين الاباحات المسجد وعقد ساعات
من قرار نتنياهو منع دخول اليهود حتى
نهايه شهر رمضان
وهذه الصور تاتينا من عاصمه ايرلندا
الشماليه بالفاست عشيه احتفالات بمرور 25
عاما على اتفاق الجمعه العظيمه وسيلقي
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن كلمه يوم غد
الاربعاء لهذه المناسبه
اما هذه الصور فتاتينا من مقديش التي
يزورها الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو بوتياريش الذي دق ناقوس الخطر
ودعا الى دعم دولي كثيفا للصومال الذي
يشهد اضطرابا امنيا
وجفافا غير مسبوق
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد التشاور مع قاده امنيين وعسكريين
نتنياهو يقرروا وقف اقتحام المستوطنين
للاقصى حتى نهايه رمضان من جزير يعتبر
قرار نتنياهو خطا فادحا قد يؤدي الى
التصعيد ولم يجلب الهدوء وفي تصعيد بالضفه
الغربيه الاحتلال يقتل فلسطينيين اثنين في
نابلس بزعن محاولتهما اطلاق النار صوب
مستوطنه
بعد تحذير البنتاجون من خطر امني جسيم
جراء تسريب وسائق امريكيه سريه الكشف عن
وثيقه امريكيه مسربه تشكك في جدوى هجوم
اوكرانيا مضاد التسريبات تثير قلق حلفاء
واشنطن رغم رسائل طمطنه امريكيه
غداه اعلان بيجين انتهاء مناورات عسكريه
حول تايوان تقول ان سفن حربيه وطائرات
صينيه لا تزال منتشره في محيط الجزيره
وسائل اعلام صينيه تؤكد ان سفن حربيه
تواصل اجراء تدريب قتالي في المياه حول
تايوان وفي بحر الصين الجنوبي الفلبين
والولايات المتحده تباشران اكبر مناورات
عسكريه مشتركه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا قرار رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بجميل نتنياهو منع وصول اليهود
الى المسجد الاقصى حتى نهايه شهر رمضان
بناء على توصيه بالاجماع من وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي ورئيس الاركان ورئيس الشباب
ومفوض الشرطه بينما انتقد وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي لتامار بن جدير قرار
نتنياهو وقال انه خطا فادح لن يجلب الهدوء
وسيؤدي الى مزيدا من التصعيد لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي ما هو سياق قرار
نتنياهو منع وصول اليهود الى المسجد
الاقصى حتى نهايه شهر رمضان وقد جاءت
نتيجه تصويتكم على النحو الاتي
32% قالوا انها دوافع امنيه داخليه بينما
راى نحو 17% انها دوافع سياسيه داخليه
فيما صوت نح و 51% بالقول انها ضغوط
خارجيه ودوليه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر عاد الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
واشنطن بوست تكشف عن تطبيق تجسس اسرائيلي
جديد يعرف باسم
تم بيعه لعشر دول واستخدم ضد الصحفيين
وسياسيين معارضين
اذن اوعز رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو بمنع وصول اليهود الى
المسجد الاقصى حتى نهايه شهر رمضان بناء
على توصيه بالاجماع من القاده الامنيين
والعسكريين بحسب بيان صادر عن مكتبه قرار
نتنياهو ياتي بعد اسبوع من التصعيد
الميداني تفاصيل تطور الاوضاع وخارطه
اقتحام المستوطنين المتشددين نتابعها في
التقرير التالي
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه من يمينه ياهو
يقرر منع دخول اليهود للمسجد الاقصى في
الايام العشره الاخيره من شهر رمضان
المبارك قرار استند الى توصيه بالاجماع من
وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان ورئيس الشباك
ومفوض الشرطه مخالفا بذلك هو وزراء التيار
الديني المتطرفي في حكومته فوزير الامن
القومي لتمر بكثير وصفه بالخطا الفادح
الذي سيؤدي الى مزيد من التصعيد المنع
يدخل حيز التنفيذ في يوم انتهاء عيد الفصح
لدى اليهود وبعد ايام من تصعيد ميداني
فجره اقتحام الشرطه الاسرائيليه للحرم
القدسي في مشهد قال عنه مسؤول اسرائيلي
انه اضر بصوره اسرائيل دوليا
وتلات تصعيد في الاقصى هجمات صاروخيه
تعرضت لها اسرائيل من غزه ولبنان وسوريا
خطوره التصعيد الاسرائيلي عكستها ادانات
دوليه واقليبيه ودعوه للتهدئه تهدئه لا
يمكن ان تتحقق للفلسطينيين طالما استمرت
الاقتحامات التي تقودها جماعه دينيه
متطرفه وعلى راسها اكثر من اثنتين واربعين
جماعه صهيونيه هدفها كما تقول اعاده بناء
الهيكل المزعوم وجميعها تندرج في اطار
الصهيونيه الدينيه التي ينتمي وزراء في
الحكومه الحاليه اليها
والاقتحامات ليست سوى جانب من محاولات فرض
تقسيم زمني للاقصى بحيث تخصص اوقات محدده
لدخول المسلمين واخرى خاصه باليهود وتحدث
خلال الساعات التي تخصصها اسرائيل لدخول
اليهود لثلاث مرات يوميا وخلال الاعياد
الدينيه وتواكب الشرطه المقتحمين وتحميهم
وتاخذ الاقتحامات مسارا اساسيا داخل
الاقصى يبدا المستوطنون من باب المغاربه
ويسيرون حتى باب السلسله لمسافه تمتد لمئه
متر تقريبا
ويتجولون في ساحات المسجد بالقرب من السور
الغربي
وتوسعت الاقتحامات حتى بات المستوطن يشبون
الاقصى بكامله تقريبا خلال كل اقتحام
والمنطقه الشرقيه بشكل اساسي
ينضم الينا من باحه المسجد الاقصى مراسل
الجزيره امين درغامي مرحبا بك امين هل
انعكس هذا القرار الذي اتخذه نتنياهو على
الاجراءات في
محيط المسجد الاقصى وعند ابوابه
نعم تحيه طيبه في الحقيقه لم ينعكس باي
شكل من الاشكال باعتبار ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه ما زالت تقيم تلك الاجراءات
الامنيه المشدده التي كانت قد فرضتها منذ
بدايه شهر رمضان وايضا شددتها منذ بدايه
عيد الفصح اليهودي قبل سته ايام وما زالت
ما زالت طبعا المصلين الفلسطينيين ما
زالوا يتعرضون لجميع اشكال وانواع
المضايقات خلال دخولهم لاداء صلاه خاصه
الفجر والعشاء والتراويح في المسجد الاقصى
لكن هذا القرار في المقابل لقي وقبل
بارتياح من قبل الفلسطينيين والمصلين هنا
في المسجد
الاقصى باعتبار ان اعداد المصلين الواحده
انها انخفضت بشكل ملحوظ خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه بالنظر الى
هذه الاجراءات والتوتر الذي احاط
بالمسجد الاقصى خلال الايام الاخيره لكن
اليوم من اللافت ان الاعداد عادت الى تلك
المستويات التي كانت عليها قبل ايام اليوم
ادى صلاه العشاء وتراويح في المسجد الاقصى
اكثر من عشرين الفا مصلين وذلك طبعا في
ارتفاع ملحوظ طبعا اليوم وهو الليله
الاولى
للعشره الاواخر من شهر رمضان المبارك هناك
صلاه
ستبدا من الساعه الثانيه ليلا الى الرابعه
وطبعا هذا لربما سيقابل من جديد بمزيد من
الاجراءات بمنع دخول عدد من المصلين وفئات
من المصلين خاصه
من تقل اعمارهم عن خمسين عاما
عودتنا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
الايام والاسابيع الاخيره منذ تقريبا
بدايه شهر رمضان لكن
ابتداء من غدا بحسب هذا القرار الذي اصدره
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو لن تكون
هناك اي اقتحامات خلال العشر الاواخر
بالرغم من ان غدا الاربعاء
سيصادف اليوم الاخير من عيد الفصح اليهودي
وطبعا هذا القرار قبل بهجوم لادع من وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي الذي انتقده بشده
وقال بانه خطا فادح ولن يسهم في اعاده
الامن والسلام لاسرائيل بحسب قوله وقال
بانه في المقابل وعلى عكس ذلك يزيد من حده
التوتر في اسرائيل بحسب قوله ايضا
لكن هناك ترقب حذر لنقل ابتداء من يوم غد
ستكون هناك او سيكون هناك تزايد لاعداد
المصلين خلال العشر الاواخر وهذا شيء
منتظر وايضا ربما هذا سيساعد كثيرا او
ستساعد بعض الاجراءات التي
ستقوم بها قوات الاحتلال خاصه على المعابر
مع كل من الضفه الغربيه وغزه بازاله او
تخفيف تلك القيود التي فرضتها منذ دخول
عيد الفتح ستساهم ايضا في وصول اعداد
كبيره من المصلين الى المسجد الاقصى من كل
من الضفه الغربيه شكرا لك مراسلنا امين
درغامي من باحه المسجد الاقصى
ينضم الينا من تل ابيب عفيفه الدار المحلل
السياسي الاسرائيلي سيد عفيفه كيف وجدت
دلالات قرار نتنياهو منع وصول اليهود الى
المسجد الاقصى حتى نهايه شهر رمضان
رمضان كريم رمضان كريم لكم جميعا
عيد الفصح سعيد لكم وعطله سعيده فهذه عطله
يهوديه ايضا
واعتقد لا يمكن لا ينبغي طرح هذا السؤال
لم يكن كانت طرح هذا السؤال قبل سنتين لان
كذلك كان امرا طبيعيا اثناء اثناء الحكومه
الماضيه التي كان يتراس حكومه الماضيه في
عام 2021 نتنياهو ايضا اصدر امرا بغلق
مسجد الاقصى
هذا هذا الموقع المقدس في اثناء شهر رمضان
اللئام العشره الاخيره
وايضا والان لكن الان نسال هذا السؤال لان
هناك حكومه مختلفه وانا نتنياهو ينظر الى
هذا الامر ليس كمشكله يهوديه ومشكله دينيه
او مساله حريه العباده بل هذا يعتبر هذا
جزء كمشكله محليه سياسيه فهو يتعرض
للانتقاد من قبل وزرائه نفسهم من اليمين
متطرف اذا الامر هو بين حزب اليقود
وسوتريتش وبنغافير ووزير الامن وقومي الذي
هو كان جزءا من المجموعه التي قررت ان
تقتحم هو غلق ذلك الصلاه
ولهذا تحديدا لهذا تحديدا نحن نسال هذا
السؤال لان نتنياهو كان يقدم نفسه على انه
لن يقدم ما يسميه هو تنازلات بهذا المعنى
ولانه كان ينتقد اسلافه لانه قاموا بهكذا
خطوه من هذا المنطلق كيف يمكن تقييم ما
قام به هذا القرار الذي اتخذه اليوم
اعتقد ان الامر يتعلق انه كان هناك تقرير
بان نتنياهو سوف يحصل على دعوه بعد ثلاث
اشهر من
بعد تجاهلته واشنطن لان الرئيس بايدن يخطط
لدعوته قبل نهايه هذا الشهر لزياره البيت
الابيض والشيء الاخر هو ايضا الرسائل هو
بدات تصله من قطر ومن الاردن
بانهما لن يستطيع ايقاف
الاضطرابات بسبب الضغوطات قادمه من ايران
وهي ايضا رساله تصله من ادارته بالذات من
الجيش
الاسرائيلي
والمخابرات
يعترض على هذا القرار ويقول انه لن يسهم
في اعاده الامن وسيزيد من حده التوتر هل
يبدو لك ذلك واقعيا
لابد ان نقول حقيقه انه في يوم امس في
التظاهر التي حصل ظهرت خرجت تظاهرا ضد
الهجوم الارهابي حيث
قتلت امراه وابنتها في رواد الاردن بن
كثير تعرض للانتقادات وكانت دجاجات ظهرت
خرج ضده من ناخبيه
بوادر ضعف وبالتالي لن اندهش لو ان كان
هذا واحد من اول
انشقاقات تحصل في التحالف الذي انهيار
جدار هذا التحالف الذي يسمى انه من اليمين
المتطرف
وسيبين انه يمكن ليبين للفلسطيني بانهم لن
يستسلموا امام الارهاب
الدار المحلل السياسي الاسرائيلي من تل
ابيب معنى الان من رام الله الدكتور هاني
المصري مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث السياسات
ودراسات الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك دكتور هاني
المصري ما قراءتك لدلالات قرار نتنياهو
هذا
دلالات قرار نتنياهو ان
نتنياهو والحكومه الاسرائيليه في حاله
ارتباك فهي في اضعف حالاتها وتدعي انها في
زروه قوتها وبالتالي تاخذ يعني قرارات
متناقضه من جهه تمنع يعني
المستوطنين من اقتحام المسجد الاقصى ومن
جهه اخرى تقوم يعني بالامس باكبر مسيره في
ضد
الفلسطينيين شارك فيها سبع وزراء وعشرين
عضو كنيست وعشرين الف مستوطن في محاوله
لاقرار بؤره استيطانيه غير شرعيه حتى
الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يريد ان تقام في هذه
المنطقه نظرا لما ستؤدي اليه من توتر ومن
اشتباكات بين اهل المنطقه وبين المستوطنين
ايضا اسرائيل بعد تاكل الردع الذي حصل
بالفتره الاخيره سواء من خلال اطلاق
الصواريخ من لبنان او من سوريا او من قطاع
غزه
اسرائيلي رادع هذا يعني انهم في حاله
ارتباك وبالتالي يجب ان يتحسب الفلسطينيون
بانهم سيقومون بضربه انتقاميه ربما بعد
الاعياد في محاوله لاستعاده يعني هيبه
الردى وهذا ما يوجد عليه مؤشرات كثيره
منها ان نتنياهو قال بان الكلمه الاخيره
لم تقل بعد ووعد المستوطنون في غلاف غزه
بانهم
يرتاحون عندما يسار يعني من الفلسطينيين
ايضا عده وزراء ليس فقط المسجد الاقصى
دكتور هاني ما الذي يخشاه تحديدا وما الذي
يحذر منه تحديدا قاده الاجهزه والجيش
الى دوله ديكتاتوريه وهذا سبب توتر كبير
بين الاداره الامريكيه وبين الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لذلك نلاحظ ان هذه الحكومه
يعني هناك عده وزراء ليس فقط بنك فيروس
مودريتش اسرائيل كاس وهم من الليكود في
دفتر وهو من الليكود طلبوا باصطياد رؤوس
كبيره واغتيال قيادات فلسطينيه ايضا هناك
مطالبه بان تنفذ عمليه سور واقي في جنين
وفي نابلس هذا يعني احتلال لمده طويله
وتنفيذ عمليه جسر العشب وتفتيش المنطقه من
بيت الى بيت وقتل اكبر عدد ممكن من
المقاومين وتصفيه البنيه التحتيه للمقاومه
شكرا لك دكتور هاني المصري مدير مركزي
مسارات لابحاث السياسات ودراسات
الاستراتيجيه ضيفنا من رام الله
وفي استمرار لحاله التوتر في الضفه
الغربيه اكدت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه مقتل
فلسطينيين اثنين برصاص الجيش عند مستوطنه
لون المقامه على اراضي قريه دير الحطب
شرقيه نابلس في الضفه الغربيه وادعى جيش
الاحتلال ان الشهيدين حول اطلاق النار صوب
المستوطنه وقال انه عثر بحوزته على مسدس
وبندقيتين من طراز امسكتين اضاف جيش
الاحتلال انه يقوم بعمليه تمشيط في
المنطقه لاعتقال الفلسطيني ثالث شارك مع
الشهيدين في العمليه ولم يصدر عن مصادر
فلسطينيه اي تعليق في هذا الشان حتى
اللحظه
[موسيقى]
مع اعلان البيت الابيض تحرك البنتاجون
بسرعه لمعالجه اي تداعيات محتمله على
الامن القومي بسبب التسريبات الاخيره كشفت
وسائل اعلام امريكيه وغربيه اقتران
الوثائق اساسا بحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا من
حيث تداعياتها ومستقبلها نستعرض ابرز ما
تضمنته الوثائق في هذا التقرير
تمثل الوثائق الاستخباراتيه المسربه وثائق
الاحاطات اليوميه لكبار القاده العسكريين
الامريكيين واللفت ان النصيب الاكبر منها
تعلق بحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فما ابرزوا
ما تضمنته تكشف الوثائق مدى اختراق
الولايات المتحده لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ومجموعه فاجنر من خلال اعتراض نظم
الاتصالات والتنصت عليها مشيره الى تحذير
مسؤولين امريكيين من تعرض جواسيس
المخابرات الامريكيه للعزله والخطر لكنها
بالمقابل ترسم صوره خاتمه بشان افق هجوم
مضاد مرتقب الربيع المقبل وتحدثت عن مكاسب
محدوده للاوكرانيين مع تحذير تقييمات
الاستخبارات الامريكيه مما سمته هنا وقصه
في حشد القوات الاوكرانيه وامدادها وفق
صحيفه واشنطن بوست ورجحت الوثيقه ان قوه
الدفاعات الروسيه وانخفاض تزويد القوات
الاوكرانيه بالذخيره قد يضاعفان الخسائر
اثناء الهجوم ويؤديان الى انهيار نظام
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني قصه
لكن هذه المره مع مصر حيث كشفت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست ان احدى الوثائق السريه
المسربه اشرت الى وجود امر من السلطات
المصريه بانتاج 40 الف صاروخ ليتم شحنها
سرا الى روسيا مع خطه لتزويد موسكو بقضاء
في المدفعيه والبارود في المقابل نقلت
الصحيفه عن المتحدث باسم الخارجيه المصريه
قوله ان موقف مصر قائم على عدم تدخل في
الحرب في اوكرانيا بينما تحدثت واشنطن عن
عدم رصد اي مؤشرات على ان مصر تقدم اسلحه
لروسيا من جانب اخر افادت وكاله اصل
استنادا الى وثيقه امريكيه مسربه بان
الجواسيس امريكيين التقطوا اشاره من ضباط
مخابرات روس وهم يتفاخرون باقناعهم
الاماراتيين بالعمل معهم ضد وكيلتي
المخابرات الامريكيه والبريطانيه لكن
الوكاله نقلت عن بيان خاص من الحكومه
الاماراتيه رفضها لمسمته المزاعب المتعلقه
باتفاق لتعمق التعاون بين واجهزه امنيه
لدوله اخرى ضد دول اخرى تشير وثيقه اخرى
تحمل ختمه سري للغايه الى ان جهاز
الاسرائيلي دعم الاحتجاجات المناهضه
للحكومه ولخطه التعديلات القضائيه في
اسرائيل وعرضت وثيقه اخرى تفاصيل متعلقه
بمناقشات خاصه بين كبار المسؤولين
الكوريين الجنوبيين بشان الضغط الامريكي
على الحليف الاسيوي للمساعده في امداد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه وبالذخائر تستمر
التفاعلات والتداعيات بينما اعتبرت وسائل
اعلام امريكيه وغربيه الوثائق المسربه
التي تجاوز عددها وثيقه ربما تكون مجرد
قمه جبل جليدي تخفي ما بعدها
وفي سلسله اخبار عاجله وردت قبل قليل وزير
الدفاع الامريكي يقول ناخذ قضيه تسريب
الوثائق السريه على محمل الجد ويكشف انه
يجري عقد لقاءات يوميه مع قاده عسكريين
كبار لمتابعه قضيه التسريبات ويقول وزير
الدفاع الامريكي ايضا ان الولايات المتحده
ستواصل العمل بشكل وثيق مع حلفائنا
وشركائنا ولن يمنعنا شيء من الحفاظ على
امن بلدنا حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الكويت الدكتور عبد الله الشيجي استاذ
الاستاذ في قسم العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت ومعنا من واشنطن
المدير التنفيذي لموقع ديفنس 1 المتخصص في
الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه مرحبا بكما سيد كيفن بار
الى اي ماده تحرج هذه الوثائق
كلها والمعلومات التي تكشفها الى عماده
تحرج الولايات المتحده مع حلفائها
اي تسريب هو في الحقيقه لابد ان يكون
احراجا ولكن اعتقد ما تحاول ان تفهمه
واصلا هو لماذا ما هي الدفع وراء هذه
التسريبات ومن قام بها فلو حاولنا ان نجعل
نجعل الاداره تبني في موقف سيء
لزياده الدعم لاوكرانيا
فهذه المعلومات تبدو تبدو بهذا الشكل ولكن
اذا كنتم معارضين اذا كان الشخص معارضا
للحرب ولا يدعم اوكرانيا ويعتبر القضيه
خاسره يمكن القول بان هذه التسريبات تكشف
ذلك ايضا حاليا هناك الكثير مسؤولين
الحكوميين يتساءلون ما هو الصحيح وما هو
الخطا والمزور في هذه التسريبات والناس
ينتظرون ان يعرفوا المزيد معلومات حول
الامر لكن بالتاكيد هذه التسريبات ام مصدر
حراج كبير للولايات المتحده دكتور عبد
الله بعض هذه الوثائق يكشف ان حلفاء
للولايات المتحده كانوا ينون ربما التعاون
مع موسكو في الحرب في حربها على اوكرانيا
رغم نفي هذه الدول ومن بينها دول العربيه
ايضا كيف وجدت ما كشفته في هذا الجانب
يعني هذا ليس جديد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تتنصت تتجسس تراقب تتابع
الحلفاء والخصوم وهذا ياتي ليؤكد بان
امريكا لا تزال على نفس المنوال يعني لا
ننسى بان ويكيليكس بالفين وعشره سرب 700
الف وثيقه وفيديو
ودراسه ومقال ووثيقه من الاستخبارات
الامريكيه ووزاره الدفاع والخارجيه وهذا
تسبب ايضا
بمئزق كبير وبنوع من الاحراج الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها وكذلك التجسس على حتى
هاتف الموبايل اللي انجل امريكا وحلفاء
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا 2013 من
وكاله الامن الوطني سرب الاف الوثائق يعني
ما لدينا الان هو 100 وثيقه وهذه الملفت
فيها انها لم يتم تحوص الحصول عليها
بالقرصنه بل بالتسريب تم تصويرها وتم وتم
اعلانها وتم نشر منذ شهر مارس يعني الغريب
انه قعدت في
سيرفس يعني بعض المواقع الاخباريه
والالكترونيه لاكثر من شهر ولم يتم
تسريبها او العلم بها الى ان بدات خلال
الاسبوع الماضي ومن سته الشهر الى الان
جبل الجليد وكره الثلج بدات تتراكم وطبعا
فيها يعني احراج كبير لحلفاء امريكا
الموثوقيه بامريكا التنصت عليهم التجسس
وما فيها حلفاء عرب كمصطر وكذلك الامارات
لتنفيان ولكن هناك في ظاهره قاعد نشوفها
الان منذ حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا هي في
العلن هناك حياد ايجابي بعدم التدخل
بدعم سواء اوكرانيا او بفرض عقوبات على
روسيا او بدعم روسيا ولكن ما تكشفه هذه
الوثائق المسربه السريه للبنتادون وللان
يجري فيها تحقيق
جنائي من قبل العدل ومن والبيت الابيض
والاستخبارات هو انه بالفعل قد يكون هناك
في محاولات للعب يعني الامريكي ضد روسيا
وروسيا ضد امريكا الان هناك يوجد في قلق
من
الجديه الامريكيه بالوقوف مع دول حلفاء
لامريكا في المنطقه وخارجها وكذلك
ما جرى تسريبه في هذه الوثائق التي ظهرت
الى العلم الى اي مدى باعتقادك سيؤثر على
الميدان في اوكرانيا والمخططات المستقبليه
لهذه الحرب
يبدو ان التاثيرات محدوده جدا لو كانت لا
يثائق صحيحه فانها تكشف حجم القوات التي
تتجمع للقيام بالهجوم
الربيعي والنوع الاسلحه اللي فيها ولكن
طبعا هذا لكن هذا طبعا معلومات جزئيه
وليست تؤكد وان اوكرانيا تقول علنا منذ
فتره بانه سيقومون بهجوم في الربيع القادم
وفي ضد روسيا ونقصهم متى وكيف وعدد القوات
وكذلك هناك انتقادات
ضمن هذه وثائق بين الولايات المتحده لا
ترى ان لاوكرانيا قوات الكافيه لاستعاده
كل الراضي الاوكرانيه ولحاق الهزيمه
الكامله بروسيا هذا ليس بالجديد هذا ليس
جديد ابدا اذا هذه نافذه محدوده ولو صدقتم
الارقام اللي فيها فهذا يعطي روسيا فرصه
ان تتوقع ما سيحصل حتى استعد للدفاع عن
نفسها ولكن كما سمعنا ان البنتاغون
والمخابرات الامريكيه والحلفاء سيحدث
سيغيرون الخطوط يمكن كما يستوجب الامر كيف
وجد سيد كاظم انه ليس بجديد هذا ربما اول
تشكيك
يعني يظهر الى العلم من جانب الدول
الداعمه لاوكرانيا في امكانيه
تقدمها وفي جد وكل هذا التسليح
هذه ليست مره اولى التي جرى مثل هذا
التشكيك الجنرميلي رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه في الولايات المتحده قال منذ شهر
نوفمبر الماضي وبشكل علني بان اوكرانيا
تؤدي عملا جيدا في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد ما
تقوم به ضدهم ولكن ليس لديها القوه
الكافيه لطرد كل الروس من اراضيها بكاملهم
حتى من شهود الارقام ليس لدي القوات
اللازمه وليست التدريب اللازم ولا المعدات
اللازمه لذلك طلب المزيد من القوه الجويه
المزيد من قوات البربائيه والدفاعات
الجويه ولو كانت هذه المعلومات صحيحه
يبين ان الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه محدوده والوقت بعد قصير عليهم
ولديهم الصحه في الصواريخ وليس لديهم الاف
16 اشهر الغربيه التي تطالبون بها منذ
الاشهر فاذا جاءتم اذا قرر الرئيس بايدن
ارسالها غدا هذه الطائره فانها لن تصرف
اليوم التالي بتطلب المسابيع والعشره لتصل
وبالتالي هناك امور كثيره تدعو القلق ولكن
نعتقدك ما تداعيات التي ستخلفها هذه
التسريبات على مسار الحرب
دوله افريقيه طلبت اسلحه تركيه ستذهب لها
ولكن ستذهب الى روسيا
سيكون لها تداعيات على اقراحات اوكرانيا
وعلى الحلفاء ولكن في نفس السياق الان
السلطات الامريكيه تؤكد انه يجري التحقيق
لمعرفه مصدر التسريب ماذا لو طال امد هذا
الامر ولم يكشف عن الشخص وراء هذا التسريب
ما خطوره ذلك باختصار لو سمحت
خطوره ذلك انه قد يكون هناك المزيد من
التسريب اذا كان من داخل امريكا اذا كان
امريكي منشاق او من داخل وزاره الدفاع
خاصه ان هناك الاف الامريكيين من عده
وزارات وليس وزارات الدفاع لديهم كليرنس
لديهم تفويض امني بان يصلوا الى هذه
المعلومات الخطيره والدقيقه والتي حتى
الصور التي تعرضونها الان هي صور مصوره من
من كاميرا على ما يبدو وتم نشرها بشكل
متعمد
لمساعده روسيا لتكتسب حتى حرب نفسيه وحتى
تتفوق يعني الان يعني حتى في كلام ان خلال
شهر الخادم ان روسيا ستسيطر على المجال
الجوي الاوكراني بسبب انخفاض عدد صواريخ
الدفاع الارضي التي لدى اوكرانيا فلها
تداعيات كبيره لا يمكن التقليل منها ويمكن
المزيد
ينشر في القادم من الايام وهذا سيضع
امريكا في حرج شديد خاصه حتى الان لا
يعلمون من اين اتت ما المصدرها ومن الذي
سربها بهذه الطريقه التي ازعجتها واحرجت
امريكا وحلفائها وافرحت خصومه على
قسم العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت
ضيفنا من الكويت وشكرا المدير التنفيذي
لموقع ديفان المتخصص في الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه ضيفنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
عام 2016 من قبل موظفين سابقين في شركه
nso الاسرائيليه وفي عام 2021
اتهمت
باستغلال عيوب هواتف ايفون لتثبيت برامج
تجسس
قال مبعوث الامم المتحده الى اليمن هانس
جرونبرد ان عمق وجديه المحادثات بين
الاطراف المعنيه في اليمن بما في ذلك
زياره وفدين سعودي وعماني الى صنعاء امر
مشجع ويعقد مبعوثون سعوديون وعمانيون
محادثات السلام مع مسؤولين من الحوثيين في
صنعاء هذا الاسبوع وقال جراند بيرج لوكاله
رويترز انه يعمل مع جميع الاطراف المعنيه
لضمان ان هذه الجهود تدعم وساطه الامم
المتحده
بدا الاطباء الجدد في بريطانيا اضرابا عن
العمل اليوم يستمر حتى السبت المقبل
وافادت هيئه الصحه الوطنيه بان الاضراب
سيؤجل اكثر بل سيؤجل اكثر من ربع مليون
موعد طبي واكدت النقابه التي تمثل هذه
الفئه من الاطباء انهم خسروا 26% من قيمه
اجورهم الفعليه منذ عام 2008
يجلس هذا البريطاني العجوز لالتقاط انفاسه
بعد رحله مضنيه الى المستشفى عاد منها وهو
ممتعد جدا اذ لم يتمكن من رؤيه طبيب لعلاج
هذه التقرحات المؤلمه التي تغطي رجليه
فالمستشفى يعاني نقصا حادا في الطواقم
بسبب اضراب الاطباء المبتدئين
كان علي ان ارى الطبيب ولكن الممرضه قالت
لي ان اعود الى البيت واتناول الشاي هذا
مزعج للغايه اشعر بانقطاع نفسي
هؤلاء بعض من الاطباء الجدد الذين يبلغ
عددهم اكثر من سبعه واربعين الفا قرروا
الاضراب عن العمل في تصعيد ضد الحكومه فهم
يطالبون بزياده اجورهم التي تاكلت على مدى
الاعوام الماضيه ووقف سياسه التقشف
الحكومي التي طالتهم ادت الى تراجع جوده
الرعايه الصحيه في البلاد
نطالب بتصحيح اجورنا فنحن لا نريد لها ان
تتقلص اكثر فاكثر فالاطباء والشباب عملوا
حتى الارهاق اثناء الجائحه ويعملون بجد مع
زياده اعداد المرضى ونعتقد انه من غير
العادل ان تظل رواتبهم متدنيه مسؤول خدمه
الصحه الوطنيه يتوقعون ان يكون هذا
الاضراب الاسوا في تاريخ الخدمه اذ يحذر
كبار الاطباء من تاثيره على حياه الامراض
المزمنه كما سيؤدي الاضراب الى الغاء مئات
الاف العمليات المجدوله
ورغم ذلك فان اضراب هؤلاء الاطباء الذي
يعتبر الثاني من نوعه في شهرين يلقى دعما
كبيرا من قبل البريطانيين الذين يعانون
ايضا جراء ازمه المعيشه وارتفاع التضخم
الى مستويات قياسيه مثل هذه الاضرابات
والاحتجاجات اصبحت امرا مالوفا بالنسبه
للبريطانيين لكنه مؤشر اخر على حاله السخط
الشعبي من اداء حكومه المحافظين التي
تسارع الزمن لترتيب بيتها قبل الانتخابات
العامه المقبله من حرب الجزيره من ساحه
الطرف الاغر لندن
[موسيقى]
الى التوتر في شرق اسيا حيث تواصل الصين
وتحركاتها العسكريه في محيط تايوان بعد
انتهاء مناورات غير مسبوقه في نطاقها حاكت
تطويق الجزيره وقد جددت الصين بلسان
الناطق باسم خارجيتها التاكيد على ان
تايوان جزء لا يتجزا من ارضها واعتبرت ان
مبدا الصين واحده هو محل اجماع المجتمع
الدولي في غضون ذلك تتاهب لما تقول انه
تهديد بيجين بالحرب اما واشنطن التي كثفت
المناورات العسكريه مع حلفائها في المنطقه
فقالت انه ليس هناك اي داعم لتصعيد التوتر
في مضيق تايوان وانه لم يحدث اي تغيير في
سياسه الصين الواحده
مازح الصينيين في كل شيء الا في مبداهم
السامي صين واحده
يقولون ان المبدا محل اجماع دولي وان قضيه
تايوان شان داخلي محض فالجزيره فيما يرون
ومثل ما لا يملون من تاكيده جزء لا يتجزا
من اراضي الصين
لكن ماذا يحوج بيجن لتاكيد الثابت
والمعروف من مواقفها
تفعلها بعدما انهت مناوره عسكريه في مضيق
تايوان ليست كاي مناورات سابقتها فهي
تحاكي فرض طوق كامل على جزيره تايوان
واحكام السيطره على البحر والمجال الجوي
والاتصالات لاحداث قوه رادعه باستخدام
اسلحه هجوميه
تستشعر تايوان ما يقول وزير دفاعها انه
تهديد صيني بالحرب استعدت له بلاده
ورئيسه البلاد بدت لها مناورات الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه عملا غير مسؤول
رغم ان الزياره التي قمت بها لدول حليفه
وتوقف في الولايات المتحده ليس بامر جديد
فان الصين استخدمت ذلك كذريعه لاطلاق
مناورات عسكريه ما تسبب في زعزعه
الاستقرار في تايوان والمنطقه وهذا ليس
موقفا مسؤولا لدوله كبيره في المنطقه
يشاطرها الحلفاء الراي واشنطن التي تفاعلت
سريعا مع مناورات الصين العسكريه في محيط
تايوان لا تريد ان ياخذ الموقف المتصاعد
هناك ابعادا خطيره
نراقب المناورات الصينيه من كثب نحن
واثقون للغايه من ان لدينا الموارد
والقدرات الكافيه لحمايه مصالحنا في
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ لكن لا يوجد سبب
لاشعال التوترات عبر مضيق تايوان وتحولها
الى صراع حيث لا يوجد هناك اي تغيير في
سياسه الصين الواحده ولا نؤيد استقلال
تايوان ولا نريد ان نرى تغييرا للوضع
الراهن بشكل احادي الجانب
حتى لا يحدث ذلك التغيير ترسل واشنطن
اشارات تريدها رادعه تجري تدريبات
المشتركه مع الجيش الفلبيني في بحر جنوب
الصين حيث النزاعات الاقليميه الحاده على
السياده وهناك وفي هذا التوقيت الحرج عزز
الامريكيون وجودهم العسكري بمدمره اخرى هي
ميليوس التي مرت بالقرب من جزر
اما الاشارات الصادره من الاوروبيين وهم
يتابعون الموقف اللاهبه في شرقي اسيا
فتروم ترجيح كفه السلم في تايوان والمضائق
كافه وهل من سبيل للسلام والاستقرار يسال
التايوانيون وقد رصدوا لتوهم كما قالوا
طائرات حربيه وسفن صينيه في محيط الجزيره
اكتملت مناورات بيجينج لكن تايبي ابقت على
قواتها في حاله تاهب قصوى فهي لم تسقط من
حساباتها ايا من احتمالات الحرب او الغزو
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم فقط من اعلان بيجين انتهاء
مناوراتها العسكريه بالقرب من تايوان بدات
الولايات المتحده والفلبين اوسع مناورات
عسكريه مشتركه في تاريخهما في توقيت تعزز
فيه واشنطن تحالفاتها لمواجهه ما تسميه
نفوذ الصين المتنامفه
يشارك نحو 18 الف جندي في التدريبات التي
ستتضمن للمره الاولى اطلاق نار بالذخيره
الحيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي الذي تطالب
بيجين بالسياده الكامله عليه تشمل
المناورات التي اطلق عليها اسم
باليكتان ويعني بالفلبينية جنبا الى جنب
تشمل تدريبات هبوط مروحيات عسكريه في
جزيره في جزيره فلبينيه قباله الطرف
الشمالي لاكبر جزر البلد لوزون الواقعه
على مسافه نح كيلو متر من تايوان وتتضمن
محاكاه عمليه انزال مرمى على جزيره بالوان
في غرب الفلبين القريبه من جزر ستراتليز
التي تطالب بها الفلبين والصين خلال
المناورات تستخدم القوات الامريكيه صواريخ
التي تعتبر من افضل انظمه الدفاع الجوي في
العالم المناورات العسكريه الجاريه بين
الولايات المتحده والفلبين غير بعيدا من
الصين وبالقرب من تايوان تندرج في اطار
تعزيز العلاقات بين الحليفين بشكل افضل
واوسع في عهد الرئيس فردينال ماركوس الابن
اي خلافا لمرحله الرئيس الفلبيني السابق
رودريغو دوتيرتي الذي كانت علاقته متوتره
مع واشنطن
التقارب في عهد ماركوس الابن تكلل بحصول
الولايات المتحده على اربع قواعد عسكريه
اضافيه احداها قريبه من بحر الصين الجنوبي
المتنازع عليه والاخرى غير بعيده عن
تايوان واشنطن ومنلا حليفتان منذ عقود
وتربط بينهما معاهده دفاعيه اوبرمت عام
2014 تعرف باسم اتفاق التعاون الدفاعي
المعزز تسمح هذه المعاهده للقوات
الامريكيه باستعمال خمسه قواعد فلبينيه
وتخزين معدات ومواد عسكريه فيها ورفع عدد
هذه القواعد الى 90 في فبراير واستنادا
الى مسؤول فلبيني فان المحادثات مستمره
بين البلدين بشان قاعده عاشره محتمله وكان
الرئيس ماركوس قد وافق على استخدام واشنطن
ثلاث قواعد في شمال البلد هي قاعده بحريه
ومطار مقاطعه كاجيال ومعسكر في مقاطعه
ايزابيلا المجاوره وتقع قاعده سانتان
البحريه في مقاطعه كاجايام على بعد نحو
400 كيلومتر من تايوان وتقع القاعده
الرابعه في ارخبيل بارابك قباله الطرف
الجنوبي لجزيره بالوان في الغرب قرب بحر
الصين الجنوبي
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيجين
رواند رونغ ون الاعلامي والبحث السياسي
ومن واشنطن معنا دنس والدر مدير مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي السابق لشؤون الصين
مرحبا بكما سيد رونجوان باي عين تراقب
الصين هذه المناورات العسكريه الامريكيه
الفلبينيه المشتركه
اهلا ومرحبا بكم الصين تراقب انكتب عن هذه
هذه المناورات
واكدت متحركه باسم فيزار خارجي الصينيه
بان هذا هذه المناورات لا يجب ان تدور
المصالح السن في هذا المنطقه وكذلك يجب
عدم التسعيد في خطر المواجهه فيها في هذه
المنطقه سيد
دانس وايلدر ما هي الرساله التي تريد
الولايات المتحده ارسالها الى الصين من
وراء هذه المناورات العسكريه المشتركه مع
الفلبين
العسكريه المشتركه مع الفلبين كانت تجري
منذ سنوات طويله وبالتالي ليست بالمناورات
الجديده ولكنها تندرج في سياق العمل
المشترك بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والفلبين لتعزيز الدفاعات في الفلبين وذلك
بسبب المستويات المرتفعه من المخاطر التي
هددت من خلالها الصين
المراكب والسفن الفلبينيه التي تبحر في
هذه المنطقه وقرب الجزر كان هناك تنمر
وهناك مضايقات تتعرض لها البحريه
الفلبينيه وبالتالي رساله الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي ان حريه الملاحه
البحريه مهمه للغايه والحلفاء في غايه
الاهميه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقف
الى جانب الحلفاء ولكن
الصين
تحاكي تطويقا لتايوان بعد زياره رئيسه
تايوان الى الولايات المتحده سيد دانس
مجددا اود ان اقول ان هذه المناورات
العسكريه ليست الاولى وهي الدوله منذ فتره
طويله ونتحدث عن 17 الف جندي
وتوقيت لم ياتي للرد على المناورات التي
اجرتها نحن نتحدث عن مناورات عاديه بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والفلبين
وليست ردا على
الاستفزازات المرتبطه بتايوان يجب ان نفهم
ذلك نتحدث عن موضوعين منفصلين
ترى ان الولايات المتحده ليس الطرف الله
ليس الدوله في هذا المنطقه وهي بعيده عن
هذه المنطقه ولا يجب التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه في هذه المنطقه باسم حريه
الملاحه
اذا كان هناك اي انتهاكا
يعني
الاقليميه الصينيه وكذلك السياده الدوله
الوطنيه الصينيه وكذلك وحده اراضيها سترد
السيم ستتخذ السين اشعاد يعني لحمايه
المصاريفها والسيادتها الوطنيه
منفصله عما يجري من توتر بين الصين
والولايات المتحده بشان تايوان
طبعا هنا السن تحث الولايات المتحده بعدم
التوقف عن يعني
استفزازيتها للصين عمل استفزازيه بسبب
التايلاند وكذلك التوقف عن التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه الصينيه وكذلك يعني
التزام بتعهداتها امام الصين وتماسك بمبدا
الصيني واحد
اذا كما قال السيد رونجو وان مساله
الملاحه
وضروره استمرارها مساله تخص دول تلك
المنطقه وهي اولويه ويعني من مصلحه الدول
المنطقه لماذا تاتي الولايات المتحده بهذه
الذريعه لتنفذ مثل هكذا مناورات ربما ترسل
رسائل توتر الى دول المنطقه
وفقا للقوانين الدوليه وقانون الملاحه
البحريه الدوليه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن مبدا
السياده على
البحار والسياده على المياه الاقليميه
بالنسبه الى مزاعم الصين بشان بحر جنوب
الصين هي لا تندرج في سياق هذه القوانين
الدوليه وبالتالي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تود ان تسلط الضوء على اهميه
حريه الملاحه البحريه في كل انحاء العالم
هذا ما نقوم به في انحاء العالم كافه
عندما تحاول اي دوله ان تفرض سيادتها على
اي منطقه لا تندرج من ضمن القوانين
الدوليه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقوم
بذلك لانه بالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده
حريه الملاحه البحريه في العالم هي في
غايه الاهميه وبالتالي نحن نح افظ على
نظام العالمي ونحن لا نقوم باي اجراءات
استفزازيه بل ان الصين هي التي تستفز
جيرانها من خلال هذه المزاعم سيد اذا ما
يسميها سيد دانس مزاعم الصين بشانه بحر
جنوب الصيني هو ما استدعى مثل هذه
المناورات ضمن القانون الدولي ما رايك
الطبع الصين
دائما تعرض حيوانات الامريكيه ترى الصين
ان هناك قوانين دوليه وهناك قوات حفظ
السلام الاماميه
فالدول الشؤون المنطقه يجب ان يحلوا
بتنسيق بين الدول الداخله هذه المنطقه ولا
يجب ان يكون هناك قادم من الخارج او
الشروط هذا العالميه تنفذ اوامرها تجاه
هذه الدول فلذلك الصين تدعم يعني التنميه
المشتركه
بين مختلف الدول وترك الخلافات الجانبا
بين الدول وهذا قد تلقى اقبالا لدى دول
هذه المنطقه ولو وبدون التدخلات الخارجيه
فالدول هذه المنطقه قادره على حل الخلافات
وتحقيق مشتركه شكرا لكم
السياسيه من بيجين وشكرا للسيد دانس
وايلدر مدير مجلس الامن القومي الامريكيه
السابق لشؤون الصين ضيفنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
انما يواجه الصومال من ارهاب وجفاف ناجم
في جزء كبير منه عن التغير المناخي مما
يخلق ظروفا مثاليه لازمه ويتطلب دعما
كبيرا من المجتمع الدولي هو ناقوس خطر دقه
الامين العام للامم المتحده
خلال زياره لهذا البلد الواقعي في منطقه
القرن الافريقي تاتي زياره غوتياريش في
وقت تعاني فيه البلاد من جفاف كارثي اوصل
الملايين الى شفير المجاعه وبحسب الامم
المتحده سيعتمد نحو نصف سكان الصومال هذا
العام على المساعدات الانسانيه وسيبلغ عدد
المتضررين من الجفاف ثمانيه ملايين الف
نسمه
الصومال ليس وحده المعني بالازمه فقد ادى
شحو الامطار خلال خمسه مواسم على التوالي
في بلدان المسلكينيا واثيوبيا الى اسوا
جفاف في المنطقه منذ اربعه عقود محنه
تذكرنا باهميه قيمه التضامن واهميه
المحافظه على موارد هذه الكره الارضيه
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على المتابعه ودمتم
بالف خير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]